[Musique]
pour beaucoup je vais suivre germain à
l'arrivée plus connu sous le pseudo
docteur noz mal logement
il a percé sur les réseaux sociaux avec
ses vlog de vulgarisation scientifique
aujourd'hui les ultra populaire sur
youtube il ya une communauté de 4
millions de personnes et chacune de
cette vidéo fait entre 800 et 2 millions
de vues il a créé était d'ouvrir les
portes de son labo voilà c'est ici où je
tourne c'est le studio il ya plein de
dax différence c'est le bordel
franchement
il ya trop de bordel il ya vraiment tout
ce que je présente
mais ce que l'on peut faire des
expériences le but c'est que
l'écoulement il soit vraiment genre
limite statique en fait j'étais prêté
donc
tu vois la regarde si tu t'approches en
fait le flux il est vraiment donc ce
qu'on appelle laminaire tu as
l'impression que c'est lui du verre en
fait j'ai un an disait direct et après
par contre il ya toutes les
perturbations et donc le gère au devient
normal mais là la base on dirait
vraiment un du verre en fait il est
statique il est fixé le scod va faire en
sorte que le ballon puisse tenir et va
contraindre les molécules d'eau à sortir
uniquement par un certain temps un
certain endroit et du coup elles vont
toutes plus ou moins dans la même
direction et former ce jeune amine r en
fait est ce qu'il ya des expériences que
tu te conseille de te le dis ça à chaque
fois il y en a certaines notamment tout
ce qui est chimique avec lot de
filtration avec des acides et tout ça il
faut pas du tout les refaire après moi
je les fais avec le bon matériel la ocz
de la sorte d'un skatepark que tout est
ouvert je mets des des gants des trucs
donc et j'y vais pour l'instant aucun
problème la poutre forme toujours une
barrière
totalement hydrophobe retour de mon bras
je vous sens pas du tout l'effet de
l'eau sur le bras
si ces fuites
ça marche très très bien hélas si je
retire
mon bras est totalement sec là toute
base avant même que la chaîne existe
avec un pote on voulait créer un super
héros qui s'appelait
knight man l'homme de la nuit en fait il
existait déjà
chez marvel froid donc mauvais choix et
en fait on l'a appelée neumann parce que
on vient de bretagne et n'osant bretons
se dire nuit
vie
pas du tout moi je suis là tout le temps
de 8 heures à 20 heures vraiment on fait
des journées de fou mais c'est ça reste
un kiff quoi et surtout dans la chance
de travailler pour nous en plus non
c'est bien j'ai toujours aimé vraiment
la biologie la physique compte donc
comprendre comment fonctionnent les
choses et tout donc après je sais venu
naturellement ce truc de vouloir
expliquer et s'il ya des bonnes qu'à des
trucs expliquer des phénomènes simple ou
compliqués et de les rendre et d'essayer
de les rendre justement compréhensible
il devrait fabriquer un nuage un centre
instantanément tu veux tout faire ou
wave asie en gros tu ta juste à mettre
un peu de vin tu me tues vide ça donc
c'est dû cesser de l'alcool à 90 dans la
bouteille ok il est vide non il y en a
un tout petit peu et ça devrait ça
devrait faire la faire je pensais que tu
vas voir peut-être à la fin
on vraiment tu mets tout intrus et pas
de soucis
maison le plus
mais quand je les fais j'en avais bien
plus donc là ça va je pense à la main ça
me dit t'as juste a fermé la bouteille
et jour tu l'as au couteau
maintenant tu as juste à mettre ça dans
l'entrée un petit trou tu mets et tu va
pomper le plus que tu peux voila voila
tu tiens comme ça et tu tues pompe le
plus désiré des voix là il ya un moment
où ça va commencer à être compliqué
mais non
tu fais c'est pour ça au fait tu as
comment dire avorter le truc
en gros quand tu fais ça tu augmentes la
pression à l'intérieur de la bouteille
en fait le l'alcool ici c'est injuste a
accéléré la réaction en fait quand tu
ouvres
il ya le fameux nuage en fait m tu te
augmente la pression tu la relâche très
très vite et en fait sa valeur va se
dilater avoir une baisse de température
et du coup la condensation intérêts
autant les gens d expérience bah je
pense que il ya le côté curiosité en
fait à mon avis j'ai réussi à réunir pas
mal de curieux en fait et surtout
en fait c'est juste la nature en fête
c'est des trucs qui nous entoure ces des
phénomènes qui nous entourent qui sont
là parmi nous et qui sont faisable en
fait par tout le monde tout le temps
quand tu veux le nuage instantanée l'a
clairement tout le monde peut le faire
et en fait ça intéresse parce que
derrière il ya des explications qui sont
relativement simples ça permet aussi de
comprendre comment les nuages se forment
plus ou moins de quoi ils sont faits et
tout est en fait il ya il ya toujours un
truc fascinant
derrière le plus simple des phénomènes
[Musique]